there is a massive revelation coming up
this weekend in a 60 Minutes interview
the interview is with former acting FBI
director Andrew McCabe Andrew McCabe in
the 60 Minutes interview admits that
number one he ordered the start of an
obstruction of justice investigation
into Donald Trump after he fired James
Comey he admits that yes it was true
that the Justice Department was
considering looking at putting together
a 25th amendment removal of Donald Trump
on the basis of being unfit or unable to
serve and yes Andrew McCabe admits
during this interview we only have a
part of this interview the full
interview will air over the weekend
McCabe admits that when rod Rosenstein
said maybe I should wear a wire when I
meet with Donald Trump it was not
sarcasm it was seriously being
considered this is so huge in that it
answers number one the question of
exactly when and for what reason did an
obstruction of justice probe start into
Donald Trump and McCabe lays it out
pretty clearly in this clip that we're
going to take a look at he did it in
order to make it difficult to make it go
away
after Andrew McCabe was gone he wanted
to establish an investigation in a way
that was documented clear and aboveboard
to make it tougher to erase the presence
of that investigation after McKay was no
longer in that position of power here's
just a segment of this interview with
Scott Pelley on 60 minutes which will
air in full over the weekend
I was speaking to the man who had just
run for the presidency and and won the
election for the presidency and who
might have done so with the aid of the
government of Russia
our most formidable adversary on the
world stage and that was something that
troubled me greatly how long was it
after that that you decided to start the
obstruction of justice and
counterintelligence investigations
involving the president I think the next
day I met with the team investigating
the Russia cases and I asked the team to
go back and conduct an assessment to
determine where are we with these
efforts and what steps do we need to
take going forward I was very concerned
that I was able to put the Russia case
on absolutely solid ground in an
indelible fashion that were I removed
quickly or reassigned or fired that the
case could not be closed or vanish in
the night without a trace I wanted to
make sure that our case was on solid
ground and if somebody came in behind me
and closed it and tried to walk away
from it they would not be able to do
that without creating a record of why
they've made that decision you wanted a
documentary record that's right that
those investigations had begun because
you feared that they would be made to go
away that's exactly right
this is absolutely monstrous now let's
talk about so that's the clip we have in
the full interview from how it's been
described so far Scott Pelley asks
McCabe about the claim that rod
Rosenstein was thinking about wearing a
wire a recording device when he would
meet with the president that was written
off as a sarcastic comment when it was
first revealed months ago Andrew McCabe
reportedly says in this interview it was
not sarcastic we were seriously thinking
it was really being considered whether
rod Rosenstein should wear a wire when
he speaks to the president given what
had taken place with Jim Comey also in
this interview you might remember that
there was a report that claimed that
there were discussions involving Rob
Rosenstein about getting the cabinet
together to remove Donald Trump on the
basis of the 25th amendment that was
also called fake news at the time from
the descriptions we have so far Pat
Andrew McCabe also confirms that in this
60 minutes interview it is stunning not
only because it is multiple stories
previously called fake news that we have
more corroboration for but the fact that
these things were happening is what is
most stunning yeah and this half
nearly two years ago at this point it's
not like since then Trump has become
more sane or that it's more of a stretch
to say that he should be removed from
office via the 25th amendment it's just
that now he has cronies surrounding him
instead of people like James Comey and
McCabe and Rosenstein who were more
independent now he has people like
Christopher Rea and Gina Haspel and
Matthew Whitaker so he's more protected
now I don't think he has only he stands
a shot at being removed from office in
that in that way anymore and Andrew
McCabe very quickly becoming enemy
number one Donald Trump taking to
Twitter this morning flipping out right
away and starting to tweet about this
saying quote disgraced FBI Acting
Director Andrew McCabe pretends to be a
poor little angel when in fact he was a
big part of the crooked Hillary scandal
and the Russia hoax a puppet for leak in
James Comey IG report on mccabe was
devastating part of insurance policy in
case i won many of the top FBI brass
were fired forced to leave or left
McCabe's wife received big dollars from
clinton people for her campaign he gave
Hillary a pass McCabe is a disgrace to
the FBI and it is traced to our country
make America yet again and of course
that is what we know of as a Gish gallop
throwing all sorts of nonsense at the
wall unrelated overlapping and
conflicting claims that are also non
sequiturs and in no way related to the
question at hand did rod Rosenstein
think about wearing a wire to talk to
trump was there a discussion about
removing trump via the 25th amendment
and of course what is the actual
reasoning behind opening up an
obstruction investigation into Donald
Trump stunning stunning and I can't wait
to see the full interview on Sunday
evening follow me on Twitter at D Pakman
we'll take a quick break and be back
with more of today's news after this one
of today's sponsors is privacy calm
slash Pakman this is a free service that
I've actually been using myself for a
while now and I love it
you just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
calms mobile app or browser extension
for fire
oxen chrome and what that does is allow
you to instantly create virtual credit
cards that are linked to your bank
account so that you're not actually
putting your real debit card number on
the internet and you use these virtual
credit card numbers to buy things online
and with one click of a button you have
the ability to create multiple virtual
cards delete cards freeze and unfreeze
cards you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from company's being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below